>> Laura: THE ESTABLISHMENT
MEDIA'S DISDAIN FOR THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS NO
SECRET.
BUT, RECENTLY ONE OF THEIR
BIGGEST TARGETS HAS BEEN
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS.
CASE IN POINT, THIS
PARTICULARLY PERSONAL
BROADSIDE FROM MSNBC'S MIKA
BRA
USELESS.
SHE DOES NOT SAY ANYTHING
THAT IS TRUTHFUL.
PRESIDENT WHO DOES THAT
EVERY DAY.
WHAT SHE IS DOING IS HELPING
DAMAGE THIS REPUBLIC.
IS WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY SARAH HUCKABEE
SANDERS WHO IS FREEZING OUT
THERE.
MERRY CHRISTMAS.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
A LITTLE COLD BUT OTHER THAN
THAT WE ARE DOING GREAT.
>> Laura: BIG NEWS ON TAX
REFORM.
BIG, BIG DAY I'VE BEEN
WATCHING YOU FOR MONTHS IN
BRIEFING ROOM.
WITH PATIENCE AND AN ABILITY
TO DEAL WITH THE CRA AT YOU
ON A MINUTE-BY-MINUTE BASIS.
HAVE YOU MORE PATIENCE THAN
I WOULD EVER HAVE.
THEN YOU HEAR COMMENTS LIKE
THAT FROM ANOTHER FEMALE, A
FEMALE JOURNALIST.
HOW DO YOU PROCESS THAT?
THAT PARTICULAR COMMENT
WHICH I FOUND, OF ALL OF
THEM SAID LATELY,
PARTICULARLY OBJECTIONABLE?
>> LOOK, IT HELPS THAT I
HAVE THREE TODDLERS AT HOME.
SO I'M PRETTY GOOD AT HAVING
A LOT OF PATIENCE IN
SOMETIMES DEALING WITH
THINGS THAT YOU DON'T ALWAYS
WHO WAS ELECTED BY THE
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN OF
THIS COUNTRY AND A LOT OF
LIBERALS HAVE CONTEMPT FOR
THESE PEOPLE WHETHER THEY'RE
MEN OR WOMEN.
REMINDER OF WHY THIS
WE ARE HERE TO GET BIG
ON.
IF THEY WANT TO FOCUS ON PET
A TACKS.
COUNTRY.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO GROW THE
ECONOMY.
CONTINUE TO CREATE JOBS.
2 MILLION NEW JOBS SINCE
THIS PRESIDENT CAME INTO
OFFICE.
I'M SURE A LOT OF THOSE ARE
GOING TO WOMEN.
AND MAYBE WE WILL GET TO
REPLACE SOME OF THOSE FEMALE
JOURNALISTS OUT THERE THAT
DON'T LIKE US VERY MUCH AT
SOME POINT.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS IS A
PRESIDENT WHO IS FOCUSED ON
GETTING THINGS DONE.
FOCUSED ON GETTING THINGS
DONE FOR THE MEN AND WOMEN
THAT FRANKLY A LOT OF THE
LIBERAL ELITES IN THIS
COUNTRY DON'T LIKE, HAVE
CONTEMPT FOR, AND HE IS
FOCUSED ON EMPOWERING WOMEN
AND HE IS DOING THAT AND THE
AND I THINK IT'S SAD THAT
HONOR.
THE MORE THEY ARE ATTACKING
THE BETTER JOB I THINK YOU
ARE DOING.
LET'S TALK ABOUT ROLE.
I THINK A LOT OF THE PEOPLE
FOX VIEWERS WATCHING NOW.
THEY WATCH YOU OUT THERE
DOING DAILY COMBAT AND THEY
THINK TO THEMSELVES OKAY.
WHAT IF SHE IS TALKING TO
THE PRESIDENT AND HE SAYS GO
OUT THERE AND SAY.
THIS BUT IT'S NOT SOMETHING
SPECIFIC ISSUE.
BUT WOULD YOU SAY TO HIM
BOSS, THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING -- THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT I'M
COMFORTABLE SAYING BUT YOU
HAS HE EVER DONE THAT?
>> LOOK, IF THERE WAS EVER A
I WOULDN'T DO IT.
THAT'S PART OF WHO I AM.
AND THIS PRESIDENT IS NOT
GOING TO ASK ME TO DO
SOMETHING I'M NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH.
IF I GET TO A PLACE CAN I
TALK TO HIM AND COME IT A
PLACE WHERE WE CAN AGREE ON
WHAT THE TALKING POINTS AND
WHAT THE MESSAGE IS, BUT
THAT'S JUST NOT SOMETHING
I'M EVER GOING TO BE PART
OF.
ANYTHING THAT I'M NOT GOING
PRESIDENT IS DOING.
I BELIEVE IN WHAT WE ARE
BETTER PLACE.
I THINK WE HAVE DONE A LOT
IN THE FIRST 11 MONTHS.
I LOOK FORWARD IN HELPING
THE PRESIDENT PUT THAT
MESSAGE OVER THE NEXT SEVEN
YEARS.
HOUR LAWYER 32% APPROVAL
RATING IN A RECENT POLL.
MONMOUTH POLL.
THE OTHER POLLS SHOW THE
PRESIDENT IN THE HIGH 30'S.
WHY DO YOU THINK AT LEAST
NOW HE HASN'T GOTTEN SO FAR
HE WASN'T GOTTEN THE CREDIT
FOR THE DEREG HE HAS DONE.
FOR THE TAX CUT OBVIOUSLY
EVERYBODY IS GOING TO GET IN
THE NEW YEAR, THE JUDGES ON
THE FEDERAL APPELLATE COURT?
RECORD PACE FOR PUTTING
JUDGES ON THE COURTS.
WHY IS THE NUMBER STILL SO
>> LOOK, I THINK A LOT OF
THE TIMES OF THE REASON THE
NUMBERS MIGHT BE LOWER THAN
THEY PROBABLY REALLY ARE IS
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE GETTING.
THEY ARE NOT GETTING ALL THE
HAPPENING IN THIS COUNTRY.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO START TO SEE THIS
IMPACT WHEN THE TAX CUTS GO
THROUGH.
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN RIGHT
AWAY.
THEY WILL SEE THE BIGGER
PAYCHECKS STARTING AS HE
SHALLLY AS FEBRUARY.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
THINGS YOU ARE GOING TO SEE.
CHANGES IN THE DEREGULATION
PROCESS.
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE THE
IMPACT OF THAT EVEN MORE
THAN WE ALREADY ARE AT THE
FIRST PART OF NEXT YEAR.
I THINK ONE OF THE BIG
PROBLEMS IS THAT STUFF
DOESN'T GET COUGHED.
TRYING TO ATTACK THIS
PRESIDENT.
TRYING TO DELEGITIMIZE HIM.
>> Laura: IT'S OVER THE TOP.
>> SOME OF THE BIG THINGS
THAT ARE HAPPENING AREN'T
THE TOP.
IT'S 90% COVERAGE IS BAD.
HE COULD COME UP WITH A CURE
FOR LUNG CANCER TOMORROW AND
BECAUSE WHAT I'M HEARING
FROM MY LITTLE SOURCES ON
CAPITOL HILL, IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT MAY MOVE TO DO A,
QUOTE:  DACA FIX, WHICH
LOTTERY SYSTEM AND WITHOUT
REDUCING ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
AND THE WALL AND ALL THAT
STUFF.
DOING THIS DACA BEFORE THE
END OF THIS YEAR.
DON'T YOU THINK THE BASE OF
THIS PARTY, SARAH, WILL GO
CRAZY IF THAT IS WHAT THE
PRESIDENT PUSHES THROUGH
WHEN WE HAVE SO MANY BIGGER
PRIORITIES HERE?
>> LOOK, THE PRESIDENT IS
FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE WE
HAVE RESPONSIBLE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
IT ENDING CHAIN MIATION.
REASONABLE DOUBT ACCORDING
TO FUNDING FOR THE BORDER
WALL AND INCREASING AN
TIESIER.
WE LAID OUT THE PRINCIPLES
THINGS WE WANT TO SEE AND
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE MAKING
SURE HAPPENS COMPLETE AND
RESPONSIBLE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
>> Laura: YOU WON'T DO ANY
CLEAN DACA QUOTE FIX THAT
SOME OF THESE REPUBLICANS
WANT.
WILL YOU?
>> LOOK, AS I JUST SAID WE
HAVE LAID OUT WHAT OUR
PRIORITIES ARE.
>> THAT'S NOT OUR PLAN.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO HAS
TALKED ABOUT, CAMPAIGNED AND
SPECIFICALLY FUNDING BORDER
WALL.
GREATER INTERIOR
ENFORCEMENT.
BETTER VETTING AND JUST,
AGAIN, MAKING SURE THAT WE
SOMETHING WE DON'TER
CURRENTLY HAVE AND SOMETHING
THIS PRESIDENT WANTS TO MAKE
SURE WE DON'T TINKER WITH IT
AND FIX SMALL PARTS OF IT
BUT WE FIX ALL OF IT.
>> Laura: SARAH, WHEN YOU
SEE A JUDICIAL NOMINEE UP
THERE YESTERDAY,
MR. PETERSON, I BELIEVE, WHO
WAS NOMINATED D.C. DISTRICT
EVIDENCE AND PROCEDURE
ISSUES THAT YOU KNOW WHEN
PAUSE ABOUT THE WAY SOME OF
THESE LOWER COURT JUDGES ARE
BEING PICKED AND SELECTED?
>> LOOK, I HAVEN'T TALKED TO
IS A PRESIDENT WHO IS
FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE WE
HAVE JUDGES IN PLACE THAT
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR ROLE
IS.
AND THAT'S NOT TO CREATE
LAW.
THAT'S NOT TO CHANGE LAW.
BUT IT'S TO BE ACTUALLY
FOCUSED ON THE CONSTITUTION
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
JUDGES IN PLACE THAT
UNDERSTAND THEIR PLACE.
>> Laura: THAT WAS A BAD
NIGHTMARE.
I'M SORRY.
BUT, I MEAN, HIS JUDGES HAVE
BEEN GREAT.
HE IS, I'M SURE, A NICE
PERSON.
HE IS GOOD AT THE FCC.
AS A DISTRICT COURT JUDGE,
SOMEONE WHO CLIRKD ON THE
FEDERAL COURT OF APPEAL HE
IS, THAT WAS A BRUTAL SERIES
OF QUESTIONS BY KENNEDY.
I HOPE DONE MCGAHN AND THE
CROWD TAKES A LOOK AT SOME
OF THE PROCEDURES FOR THE
DRICKET SECURITY.
SARAH, DO YOU MAKE.
>> IF YOU HAD MY PECAN PAY I
COULD SHAKE YOUR MIND.
I HAVE MIGHT HAVE WON OVER
APRIL RYAN FOR A DAY OR TWO.